he's damian lillard the pride of Weber
State and the Portland Trailblazers are
you watching the game tonight Damian
yeah I'll be watching you okay what do
you think of my logic here of the
Raptors winning this series I mean I
think it's very possible
it's a to me it's a 50/50 series I think
go to state obviously is a championship
team they've been there done that and no
more than one or two occasions but I
think is put out Kady without boogie you
know one of the things during her even
during the regular season that we had
successfully against Golden State one
would beat them twice was Newark in the
paint you know just offers and
rebounding him scoring on the Block
demand the double-team and I think they
have something like that in Marc Gasol
they just a really deep team you know
they they defend and they get production
from a lot of guys you know so I think
that could present a problem for Golden
State
but Goldy statements also go to state
great series if you could play against
Hawaii you could play against Steph who
would you rather play against I mean
both are tough you know Kauai wrong do
what he does is gonna be you're gonna
get a lot of touches you owe me a lot of
ISO ball I'm usually not match that
would have but just defensively you know
he's active he's always in the way help
him get his hands in there he's on the
ball you gotta be on high alert doesn't
talk at all during a game the referee
does it but never discussed curry talk
to you yeah I mean Stephanie just
easygoing Stephanie just you know he'll
he'll talk to you like it's not really
competition out there you know I'm kind
of different like one other you know not
angry but I'm like not very friendly so
I was just like I'm just playing
whatever no he'll interact with
everybody
do you wish he was a little more
competitive issue was more like
Brook boo Steph no I mean I like him for
who he is or what he is I mean he plays
the game with you know a lot of jewelry
and you know there's not a lot of
animosity he has fun you know I think
you know he's he's effective that way
he's got too emotional about things I
have it on the floor he just plays with
Joey and he's telling about their him
and I do what he does I had the highest
level soon you know I don't have a
problem with it at all I love his game
what about dream on he likes to talk a
little bit he dream on is very vocal
yeah he does the dirty work there and
and I mentioned this a couple of times
on the show for Steph and the rest of
that team to sort of say to Kevin Durant
hey come on in we'll make it your team I
mean it's really a big sacrifice on
Steph's part now all of a sudden people
are going you know that Steph Curry with
Kevin Durant out he's still pretty good
I'm like he's always been great it's
just I think that he and Raymond allowed
Kevin Durant to be the star of this team
what do you think why wouldn't you you
did a guy like Kevin Durant dominate
your team why would you try to compete
with him you know this dude is probably
you know the best player in the league
so why would you try to compete with
being the best player when he's gonna
make the game easier for you you know
you don't take some of the workload off
of you
you know that can add years to your
career what's the defensive strategy
against Golden State
what did you guys try to do buzz we want
delivers a three-point shots we want to
make them play the paint you know a lot
of day runs is them making a bunch of
threes you know getting excited the ball
movement you know all that stuff so we
wanted we did a lot of switching
different threes but they no one
championships the way there for a reason
you know they they get to what they want
to do well I thought we did a solid job
you know just for most of the game but
those moments that you don't keep it
they'll gonna run you mean 300 for games
yet a 16 17 point lead and it slipped
because we weren't able to sustain you
know our coverage isn't you know that
small slip-up in your Kalu's your game
obviously what's it like though when you
know they're on a run and there's
nothing you can do about it I mean it is
something you could do about it's just
that when it doesn't work out you know
it can be you know large near their
favor and that's when they on the run
you know you got to just you can't be
discouraged you got to keep defending
you got to stay on them but you got to
play good off its and score the ball
make them work on a defensive end when
you're not scoring you know they're just
getting it off the rim and they pushing
it you know there are some old-school
guys handling the ball multiple guys
looking for shooters to set screens and
they delivered a book you know they
grade it and what they do drinks
anything to you when you play against
the Raptors he doesn't say anything to
you you'd be the guy that I'd want to
try to get into your head at least being
the best player on years ago lewis
playing he was saying little stuff to me
but I already know so much pay attention
to he wants to play so badly Damon he
wants to be in the game so bad doesn't
it yeah I mean he had a line in a song
what's the music is so synonymous
because we want to beat him and they
want to be yes and I think that's
perfect aligned to him would you trade
places with Drake when I say plays nah I
love the game too much would you trade
places with jay-z oh probably not you
you at least thought about that one a
little bit more than Drake
I mean jay-z was a round you know D inve
I mean you've been around a long time so
you know maybe those experiences but I
mean like I said my love for the game
was great you know just being able to
come play at this
one play at a time when I'm playing
whether financially is like what better
time to be in the NBA
there's everything about the league
right now you know how its evolved in
favor of the players you know I don't
think I want to get it it's reported a
week ago that you're going to sign a
4-year supermax deal where do you stand
with your contract I'm just waiting
right now I think you know obviously
it's something that most likely don't
happen and you know I'm just waiting yes
we haven't really met about it we
haven't done anything no soliciting but
if I told you when you write Weber State
I would say Damian you know in around
2020 you're gonna make about forty five
million dollars a year in the NBA what
would you say I wouldn't believe it
because when I was coming out of school
in my mind I was just like you know I
might have to claim his e League I might
have to you know throw a few years
without playing you know stuff like that
I was prepared for for that route and
you know I just kept kept my head down
kept doing my work and then he
eventually get turned into this but I I
in my mind come from Weber State you
know my coach that I trained with had it
in my mind that I was gonna be like a
more of a journeyman to dogs I have to
earn my hmm
or my stuff in that type of way so if
you make a donation to Weber State they
could change it to Lillard State they
probably change the school you know if
you made a nice little donation there
are you interested in doing that I mean
the donation maybe but I doubt when did
you know you could play when did you
know you belong in the NBA do you have
one of those moments of enlightenment
oh I think my my sophomore year I sound
weird College oh you knew you could play
in the NBA then but when did you know
you could be a star in the NBA Marit
here yes when I realized you guys know
people was talking about how maybe it
wasn't my game with the translated plant
like NBA level
Modesto and uh I got in the league and I
was like Mormon says I can get jumpers I
can you know manipulating my way to
spots all that stuff so I figured on
that and I was like okay I could be one
of the best are you doing anything fun
this summer I got some plans I knew
nothing when I what I usually doing this
got another album coming out I'm not
sure I'm sure drop some music but I I
don't know if I'd go for if I said you
could collaborate with anybody with
anybody here Jake oh okay have you tried
to yeah I'll put in a good word for you
appreciate ya that's the least I can do
yeah hey Congrats on the season have fun
in the off season always great to check
in with you and thank you again Damian
Damian Lillard he's number zero to
represent that journey from Oakland to
Ogden Utah Weber State for more Dan
Patrick show tune in the audience
channel 239 on DirecTV
stream for free on BR live or download
the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]